نذهب الان الى امريكا وابرز الاحداث لعام
20 22 من واشنطن الزميله ريتا سليمان
مراسله صباح العربيه ريتا يسعد هالصباح
اولا واسمحي لي انا اسواك بالكلام قبل ما
تحكي لنا اي شغله عن احداث امريكا اكثر
شخص حصل معه تغيرات في 20 22 غادرتينا
غادرتينا لامريكا وانتقلت بقيتي في نفس
المجال ونفس المكان بس من مذيعه في
الاستديو الى مراسله واثبتنا نجاحك وتميزت
اكثر فاكثر ريتا هذا اللي لي اقوله كل عام
وانت بالف خير ولك دائما محبه والاحترام
وشخص عزيز دائما تفضل
صباح معكم اصلا انه طعم مختلف تماما من
صباحاتنا
الميك اب برو بالاستديو همم لا هون هلا
همم
سنه 2020 فالطبع سنه التحديات همم على
المستوى الشخصي وعلى المستوى العملي ايضا
وعلى همم ايضا للولايات المتحده همم ايضا
ان كان في على المستوى الشركات شركه ابل
وصله قيمتها الى حد ثلاثه مليون دولار
وهذا امر كبير جدا هنا في الولايات
المتحده هذه اعلى نسبه تصل اليها شركه
امريكيه في التاريخ همم ايضا على المستوى
الفني همم لا ننسى الصفحه الشهيره التي
وجهها
ويل سميث في الاسكارس
همم قبل دقائق قليله من الحصول على جائزه
افضل ممثل طبعا طبعا ما دفع المنظمين
لحرمانه من الحضور همم 10 سنوات ايضا على
المستوى الفنيه همم
المحاكمه الشهيره بين امبير
بتهمه التشهير المحكمه اتهمت همم
الزوجين السابقين
هاعمل تشهير المتبادله هذه المحاكمه
استمرت من ذو الحدث عشر من ابريل حتى
الاول من يونيو وانتهت في الحكم على لصالح
جوني ديب ايضا همم على المستوى القانوني
الغت- محكمه امريكيه العليا الحق الدستوري
للمراه في الاجهاض وهذا امر بالبالغ
الاهميه هنا في الولايات المتحده فقدت
حوالي 66 مليون امراه في سن الانجاب الحق
القانوني في الاشهار الذي كان قانون
قانونيا في اكثر من 50 همم
ولايه ولمده 50 عام همم ايضا انصقل الى
المجال الفضائي والتحديات الاولى مع ظهور
المجموعه الاولى من الصور كامله الالوان
من ثلاث جيم الفضائي للنجوم ومجره سعيده
وبدقه عاليه لم يسبق لنا او لاي انسان همم
النظر اليها بهذه التفاصيل صحيا ايضا كان
هناك تسجيل خرق كبير في القطاع الصحي
خصوصا مع مرض الالزايمير اكتشاف عكار تمكن
بشكل فعال من ابطاء تقدم هذا المرض همم لا
يمكن ان ننسى المجال التقني ووسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي التي اخذت حيز كبير همم
من الاخبار هنا في السابع والعشرين من
اكتوبر ايضا استحواذ لهم ماسك على تويتر
رسميا وبدا حكم التعبير بيطارد عدد كبير
من الموظفين وكبار المدراء التنفيذيين
وايضا باليوم التالي في الثمن والعشرين من
اكتوبر شهدنا نهايه عهد الازدهار همم
التكنولوجيا طبعا هذا كان باختصار مجمل
الاحداث وطبعا نتمنى للجميع عام جديد مليء
بالخير والصحه اليكما احنا نشكرك جزيل
الشكر بنقول لك تصبحي على خير شكرا